- [Narrator] This episode
of Wheel of Science
is brought to you by Wix.
- On this episode of Wheel of
Science, we're talking aliens.
I think I'm pregnant
with a little snake-man.
- (laughs) This is Wheel of Science.
(upbeat game show music)
- Hey everybody, welcome
to Wheel of Science.
I'm your host Chuck Nice
and this is the interactive show
that answers your questions
about the universe.
I don't answer your
questions about the universe,
your very own personal astrophysicist,
Dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson,
answers your questions.
What's up, Neil?
- I'm back home in New
York but I happen to,
at this moment, be at New York Comic-Con.
- Comic-Con, huh.
Okay, what's the most
interesting costume you've seen?
- I saw one that looked
like a very convincing alien
and then I realized, if
that was an actual alien,
no one would notice.
They landed on the wrong day. (laughs)
If you're trying to visit humans,
don't land on Comic-Con days, okay,
'cause then you'll just blend right in.
You gotta come on some other time,
just instructions for the
aliens when they come visit.
- There you go, sage
advice, sir, sage advice.
What time is it, Neil?
- It's time to spin the wheel.
Bring it on.
(digital siren buzzes)
- [Chuck] Pedro Duran
Monteleone wants to know this:
What can Drake's equation
tell us about aliens?
- Oh, so Drake equation was a way
to organize our ignorance of the universe
when we're trying to figure out
if we can communicate with
intelligent aliens in space.
It's named after Frank Drake.
He first wrote this equation,
I think it was the late '60s,
might have been early '70s.
You start out with the
number of stars in the galaxy
and then you say, well what
fraction of those have planets,
what fraction of those that
have planets have life,
what fraction of those
have intelligent life,
have intelligent life with technology,
what fraction of those might actually
be listening for us at any given moment.
You start hacking away at this number
and what's left at the end is an estimate
for how many civilizations are out there
that you might want to talk to.
And, each one of these terms,
is an astrophysical question.
You can back it up further
and say, what is the rate
the stars are being born
because that will tell you how many stars
you have to search for.
So, when you put all these terms together,
you get an estimate of how many
intelligent civilizations
might be out there.
And right now, in one of my recent books,
we actually give the very
latest calculation for this
and there's like, billions, so we're good.
- Do we really wanna talk
to billions of other people?
- Yeah, I don't know if you,
or tell them where you
live, that would be bad.
You don't give strangers,
who are your own species,
your email address,
much less sending the
return address to Earth
out to aliens across the galaxy.
- Whew, alien stranger danger.
Alien stranger danger!
- And Chuck, you know what
the last term in the Drake equation is?
It's how long the intelligent civilization
might be around at all.
It could be that achieving
high intelligence,
you now know enough how to
render yourself extinct.
So, just because you became
intelligent with technology,
doesn't mean you will keep
that for all the rest of time.
Maybe you have an expiration date.
- Well, hopefully, we don't push that
date up further than it has to be.
All right, let's move on, Neil.
- Bring it on.
(digital siren buzzes)
- [Chuck] Don Rihm wants to know this:
How likely is the theory of panspermia
for the genesis of life on Earth?
- It's really good.
If you look at microbes, not all microbes,
some microbes are just
fine in the high radiation,
low temperature, dehydrating
conditions of space
and we have them here on Earth.
And you say, why do you have
this ability to resist this?
That's not a natural force
operating on your
evolutionary history here.
But you would need that getting
through the vacuum of space.
Asteroid impacts kick rocks
into interplanetary space
and they travel and they
land on other planets.
There's some number of
tonnage of rocks on Earth,
that actually came from Mars,
came from other planets
in the Solar System,
so panspermia is the movement of microbes
from one planet to the other
in the nooks and crannies of the rocks,
especially in the crannies. (laughs)
- Panspermia, the Earth
got banged by a comet
and impregnated with life.
It's beautiful.
All right, judging from that reaction,
it's time for a break.
We'll be back with more Wheel
of Science, right after this.
- [Narrator] Thanks for Wix for sponsoring
this episode of Wheel of Science.
Did you know that our fastest rockets
take days to reach the moon
but using Artificial
Design Intelligence on Wix,
will allow you to build a website
in a fraction of that time?
- Yeah, I like this, let's do it.
- [Narrator] With ADI, you
just answer a few questions
and your site is almost ready to go.
Go to Wix.com/go/StarTalk and
begin your site right now.
- All right, welcome back.
Let's get right to another question, Neil.
- Spin the wheel, bring it on.
(digital siren buzzes)
- From Sanjeez Baskar:
Considering the environmental conditions
of Mars versus Europa,
where are we most likely to find aliens?
- My bet is on Europa
because that has an ocean of liquid water
beneath the frozen layer of
ice, maybe a kilometer thick,
but that ocean's been liquid
for billions of years,
billions of years and on Earth's oceans,
that's where all evidence
points to life having begun.
So, if you wanna find life as we know it,
we're gonna look for
conditions as we know it
and that would be these oceans in Europa.
And then the only thing
left is if you do find life,
what do you call it?
And I think there's no choice
but to call them Europeans.
(laughs silently)
- I'm gonna have a moment
of silence for that joke.
All right, it's caption time.
We put this picture up on our page
and asked for your best captions.
And the winning caption is Trey McCoy:
It was so big, you had
to hold it like this.
To this day, the best
burger I've ever eaten.
(laughs)
I just love it because
it has nothing to do
with astrophysics or the
cosmos, it's pretty cool.
- Except that burgers are oblate spheroids
and anytime you have
objects in the universe
that rotate very quickly,
they'll spread out at the equator
and in the limiting case, you get burger.
I'm just sayin'.
- Who knew Earth was so delicious?
(laughs)
Hey Neil, here is a comment
from our Wheel of Science group.
Staci Radford-Vincent says, "Hi!
"I've been watching Wheel of Science
"with my sixth grade
students and they love it!
"I've encouraged them to
submit questions to me
"on the coming topics and
then I can send them in."
- Excellent.
So, Chuck, that means you can't be
so potty mouthed from now on,
now that we have sixth graders
watching Wheel of Science.
- Neil, who do you think
I learned this from?
Those sixth graders.
(laughs silently)
And now it's time for our poll.
Our question: Will we communicate
with extra terrestrial
intelligent life in our lifetime?
Answer the poll right here
and, Neil, any thoughts?
- Maybe.
But that's not a legitimate answer is it?
I don't know.
You want a yes or a no, don't you?
Yeah, I would say, I hope not
because if we do, they are way smarter
and more technologically able than we are
and anytime that's happened
on Earth, it hasn't boded well
for the one who did not
have the technology.
- Hmm, so what you're saying is
you'd rather us communicate
with dumb aliens?
- Yes! (laughs)
Because otherwise, they will
just make us their pets.
- Well, that's our show
and it was a good one.
As always, we have to say thank you
to the one, the only,
Dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson.
Thanks, Neil.
- Thank you, Chuck, and as always,
I bid you to keep looking up.
(fun game show music)
- Can I stop looking up now?
- [Narrator] Hello,
Earthlings, it is time to do
what you humans do best,
do things on the internet.
That's right and you can do
it with total design freedom.
Wix is the best place
to make your personal
or professional website.
It does everything you can
possibly want it to do.
Wix has industry leading SEO tools
to help you rise above the rest.
Also, Wix automatically creates
mobile optimized versions of your site,
so it will look spectacular on any device
and with advanced design features,
like animated background
and scrolling effects,
it'll look like you have decades
of web design experience.
- We could actually make
the background a video?
- [Narrator] Head over
to Wix.com/go/StarTalk
and start designing your site today.
That's Wix.com/go/StarTalk
and be the design star
that you know you are.
- Wow, all right, look at that.
Hey, thanks for watching.
We'll see you next time
on Wheel of Science.
You can look down now.
(fun game show music)